hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one sonic rajee's
introduces this wise woman Theo de ma
into his speech he was going to initiate
him into the mysteries of where the
knowledge of love he's going to address
the problem first that he brought up
with Agathon Agathon had said love was
beautiful love who's good Socrates got
him steered all the way to the other
extreme where you know you see all these
these extremes right here love was no
longer beautiful love was no longer good
because love desired beauty and goodness
now the implication of that is that love
is if lovely experi Lamas ugly right and
if LA blacks goodness love must be bad
do tamiya is gonna say to socrates well
you really need to thank this through do
you think that if something isn't
beautiful its therefore all the way at
the other extreme and ugly or could it
just be you know let's say so-so right
not ugly and in the sense of you know
scaring somebody or offered driving them
away but a rather in the sense of not
much to look at right same thing can be
said for knowledge and ignorance we'll
come back to that one in a moment
there's something in between there right
and between good and bad there's
let's call it Midway right you know some
people are genuinely good people they
have a lot of virtues they can act the
right way when they're supposed to
willingly but also by habit other people
are bad they're in a different extreme
don't walk down a dark alley with them
others they're in the middle you know
they could be good they could be bad
made it's because they don't really have
a fully developed character maybe it's
because they're kind of a mixture of
goodness and badness so in certain
situations you get the idea right
and between knowledge and ignorance or
wisdom and ignorance there's the realm
of opinion hopefully right opinion but
the problem with opinion in the Platonic
sense is that you can never quite be
sure that it's right opinion right it'll
be right for a certain amount of time
you happen to get lucky but maybe you
didn't really understand what you were
getting into so therefore the next case
that you turn to it won't be quite right
the key idea here is that there is a
middle or let's put it in this way
mediating term that allows us to go from
one to the other there's a perhaps
continuum or at least things arranged in
such a way that although they may not
grate into each other you know with
perfect continuous Ness there's some you
know discreteness to them they can at
least be arranged in a kind of scale so
she's going to go on and talk about love
in this way so if love is not beautiful
that doesn't necessarily mean love as
ugly law could be somewhere in between
if love doesn't have an doesn't have
knowledge it doesn't mean that love is
totally ignorant love could have opinion
and hope that it's right opinion if love
isn't totally good doesn't have all the
virtues that doesn't mean that love is
is suddenly at the other extreme and
terrible it could be in between it this
is part of what it means to laugh
there's two different ways you might say
of lacking right there's lacking totally
and then there's lacking partially so
she goes on and she says why must you
insist that what isn't beautiful is ugly
and what is good is bad coming back to
LOB you've been forced to agrees neither
good nor beautiful but that's no reason
for thinking that he must be bad and
ugly he's in between the two so love as
a guy love is a force long as what we're
talking about here why is in between and
is a kind of mediator and then he says
well Socrates says this doesn't make any
sense I thought love was supposed to be
this great God here's where this other
schema comes in right love is also a
mediator in another way the gods
themselves
Elia says Plato conceives of them and as
deodorant talks about them they're
blessed or happy they're beautiful
they're good and they're wise there's
nothing they lack although you know of
course we have the anthropomorphic
conception of God and we have to worry
about them a little bit just put that
aside for a moment the gods are the guns
are plenitude they have everything that
they need there's nothing that they're
lacking they they're on the extreme side
over here what about human beings human
beings are kind of like I put here a
mixed lot you know some of them are ugly
some of them are beautiful some of them
actually have some knowledge at least of
some things some of them are totally
ignorant so ignorant that they don't
even realize how ignorant that they hire
right yeah the same thing with moral
goodness moral badness most of them tend
to be in the middle somewhere at least
that's the way Plato thinks of it but
even so they're very different than the
guys right and there is no direct
connection
according to do Dima between the gods
and the human beings there's literally
no dialectic between them work there is
a dialectic Coast's between them it
happens through intermediaries that are
called da Monet's this is you know
gradient rendered as demons later on you
know in the shift to other ways of
thinking about this but the Greek sense
doesn't have any pejorative sense it
just means something in between
something like a
in between the gods who are fully divine
and human beings who are not divine who
are mortal who are Flatow right the
dynamo days are the go-between between
the gods and the human beings so a head
shall say they are the interpreters they
are the ones who are involved in making
things happen in this entire realm when
divination takes place presumably
divination is you know finding the will
of the gods it doesn't happen straight
off by it by the gods just revealing
something to human beings in this schema
rather the gods have some go-betweens
the gods reveal things to human beings
through these intermediaries love it's
in here love is not a god love is not a
mortal he's somewhere in between
he's half-and-half you might say and so
she goes on and she says here we go what
are these these die monet's they're
envoys and interpreters that fly between
heaven and earth they form the medium of
the prophetic arts of sacrifice
initiation sorcery that divine will will
not mingle directly with the humans love
is one of these and then Socrates yes
well his parents and now she's got this
interesting mythological story about why
love is in-between he says to make it
really short
love is a you might say mixed child
right there's this this God we could
translate it as resource or or plenty
right he goes to a party he gets drunk
he passed this out and then penury or
need or poverty passes by and she thinks
man if I could just get a kid by this
guy I'll be all right because I am
totally destitute but he is totally
loaded so I'm going to have sex with him
get pregnant and then have a baby and
then it'll be easy street for me
we don't actually find out whether
that's the case love is born of both of
them and
love combines the aspects of both so you
know she'll go on and she says here we
go as the son of resource in need it's
its feet to be always needy nowhere does
he delicate and lovely but her she arid
barefoot and homeless sleeping on the
naked earth and doorways in the very
streets between the beneath the stars of
heaven always / taking of his mother's
poverty what he also brings his father's
resourcefulness to his designs upon the
music beautiful and the good he's always
after what is beautiful and good and he
has got the drive to try to get it he's
impetuous he's energetic he's a mighty
hunter he's a master of device and art
of this at once desirous and full of
wisdom lacking and having at the same
time paradoxical love he has you know
it's not just like a half and a half you
know in the very middle like this it's
rather of love is all over the map
love is energy and so Anna's a diamond
when love takes hold of us love elevates
us into at least to some degree the
divine it takes us away from our purely
human mortal condition and introduces us
to something greater here's where we
want to come back to this so you know if
we look at this in a static way
especially with this one right here
knowledge opinion and ignorance we can
say well you got the state of knowledge
that's great that's wonderful if you've
got that then there's invariance clearly
we know what that is ignorant of
ignorance are we
and then there's opinion and that's just
sort of in between the mediating term is
where desire occurs according to do de
bois the one who merely has opinion and
is a-okay with that is in a certain
sense deficient what really goes on
according to do - ma is the ones who
have opinion can be oriented towards
having something more than opinion once
you become aware of the fact that all
are mere opinions and they're not you
know truly reliable because you don't
really possess knowledge then you have a
desire to obtain knowledge a desire to
become wise a desire to become expert in
something and you might say what's going
on here is mediation is leading towards
or tending towards what it is that it
lacks but it's oriented by that and by
being oriented by that it becomes in a
certain way better in the process you
know the ignorance they're badly off and
they don't seem to even care how
ignorant they are that's part of what it
means to be ignorant so in a certain way
those who possess mere opinion and
aren't even sure whether it's right
opinion or not they're not even really
opinionated they're really more ignorant
than anything else so he goes on and he
says longeth fits in here love is a
seeker after knowledge or wisdom or
truth he says none of the gods are
seekers of truth they don't long for
wisdom why they're already wise right
you must understand that they don't do
that why would the wise be seeking the
wisdom that's already there the ignorant
don't seek the truth that's why they're
so ignorant he says what are these
seekers after truth is there neither
wise nor ignorant they are those who
come between the two and one of them is
love wisdom is concerned with the
loveliest of things and love is the log
of what is lovely so it follows that
love is a lover of wisdom beating such
he's placed in between wisdom and
ignorance
who else is placed between wisdom and
ignorance well this is where we get to
Socrates profession itself we often when
were talking about philosophy
particularly in an introductory class
say you know philosophy the love of
wisdom right and it's actually not the
eros term that's being is there but the
philia term but that's often used in an
erotic way within platonic dialogues
what does the love of wisdom really
consists in does it consist in just you
know admiring wisdom
from afar no it consists in desiring and
going after wisdom as a good as
something valuable for oneself something
worth sacrificing for philosophy in its
deepest sense according to this teaching
about love the intermediaries it is in
fact the pursuit of wisdom the desire
that drives us to seek out wisdom the
wisdom that we don't yet possess and to
hold on to little bits of it that we
happen to get ahold of that means that
love is in fact a philosopher and it
means that love is what has to be
present what has to be driving to take a
philosopher that would be philosopher
from the realm of mere opinion into the
realm of knowledge or wisdom love is not
yet knowledge but love is what takes us
in that direction acting as a mediator